[Music]
all right welcome to this Friday special
edition of Hannity well it looks like
tonight breaking news RFK Jr after treat
being treated like garbage by the entire
Democratic uh party and the media mob he
now planning to announce according to
reports a third-party Run for the
presidency so what impact will that have
on the race that's anybody's guess uh as
of now we'll have details coming up
straight ahead also tonight well we are
at the end of what is another disastrous
week for your President Joe Biden look
at this the vast majority of Americans
believe Joe is mentally physically
incapable of being president he could
barely walk down the baby steps of Air
Force One even with new special shoes uh
since they started operation keep Joe
from falling his own staff working
overtime to keep that from ever
happening again and guess what so far
got off to a pretty bad start he looks
terrible
and by the way he's now literally
drawing comparisons to the keeper I
mean he just looks awful he's now losing
a Donald Trump by whopping 10 points in
that poll conducted by the ABC in the
Washington Post nearly two-thirds of
Democrats they want someone else to run
according to NBC News and their latest
poll according to Politico quote some
Democrats they are terrified about
Biden's chances for winning another
White House term he's now also facing a
very serious impeachment inquiry that
got started yesterday with now a
mountain of evidence pointing to bribery
corruption money laundering and worst of
all Biden's policies have been awful the
impact on millions of Americans they are
now suffering a as a result of bid
namics many Democrats saying you might
want to stop using that term by the way
it's been a disaster his economic
policies his energy policies Biden
inflation back on the rise interest
rates they're about to rise again also
American Savings wiped out interest
rates at a two decade High uh and about
to go even higher credit card debt the
highest ever gas prices nearly double
what they were under Donald Trump yet
again now climbing up to the $4 a gallon
Mark and now predictions that a barrel
of oil will soon be $150 a barrel and
going higher bankruptcy's never been
higher
and look at the border would a competent
leader ever allow this to happen for
three straight years by the end of this
three-year period we'll probably have a
whopping 8 million illegal immigrants
that Joe has aided and eded into this
country against our nation's laws but
don't worry listen to Karine Jean Pierre
just flat out Ling again like they've
been lying The Border's closed The
Border's secure here's the latest
lie the the president has done more to
secure the border and to deal with this
issue of immigration than anybody else
he really has no he really hasn't
there's nobody been worse On the Border
than Joe Biden record-breaking illegal
immigration record amounts of drug
trafficking opioids fentanyl a record
number of deaths from Fentanyl and other
dangerous drugs cartels well guess what
they're charging entry into the US
they're making billions of dollars also
billions of us tax dollars spent to
provide all the food the housing the
health care the education uh and legal
expenses for you know what will be 8
million people it looks like by the end
of the year all of Joe's illegal
immigrants I wonder because we're not
vetting them how many terrorists might
have gotten across that border how many
tariff cells may now exist because Joe
Biden has not vetted the people that
he's allowed in he's not followed the
law and this week the president he was
in Arizona but never bothered to visit
the Border it is a border state instead
he gives a speech near Phoenix dedicated
to his hatred of Republicans or Maga
Republicans take a look I insisted that
they
meet and uh I take credit oh I didn't
see all up
there oh don't jump don't
jump from the speech I made at
Gettysburg in inaugural address to the
anniversary of June 6th Insurrection our
January 6th Insurrection to Independence
Hall in Philadelphia an
idea that we are all created equal
endowed by our in the image of God
endowed by our creator to be be able to
treated equally throughout our lives
we've never fully lived up to that idea
in Europe the NATO meeting I sat down it
was in Fe febu January after being
elected the late Jan early February and
it was in
England mumbling stumbling bumbling
incoherent and uh what happened on was
June 6 oh January 6th uh we get it Joe
you hate half the country uh and frankly
your policies are killing all the
country he probably didn't even remember
Arizona is that border state and the
southern border is not safe enough for
him to even visit on the one side it's
controlled by dangerous Mexican cartels
on the other side you have thousands of
unvetted people from all over the world
just pouring in thanks to his invitation
every day and is outright lying about it
then of course there are a lot of you
know uneven uh surfaces at the border
Biden could actually trip and fall well
that would be risky for operation keep
Joe from falling again especially in his
condition and meanwhile we did have Tech
Mogul Elon Musk all credit to him he
actually spent time to visit the border
to see for himself to learn what's
really going on and and keep in mind
musk immigrated to the United States is
very pro-immigration legal immigration
but he's now sounding the alarm about
the record flow of illegal immigrants
warning that it will lead to a collapse
of Social Services in this country he's
right but it doesn't take a rocket
scientist to figure all of this out but
for some reason the administration
continues to just tell blatant lie after
blatant lie about the Border being
secure uh no nobody's crossing the
border blah blah blah as if we don't
have the video and statistics to prove
it your eyes are not lying to you the
hotels are packed full of illegal
immigrants in New York City and that
Sanctuary you know state that they
wanted to create now they're saying
don't come here we can't afford it they
expect to spend 122 billion in the next
18 months $40,000 they say it cost for
each illegal immigrant in New York City
and then you have congresswoman
Alexandria Casio Cortez trashing Elon
Musk in his visit accusing a republican
Congressman that joined Elon Musk of
taking a joy ride with the billionaire
maybe she's mad because she's being
criticized for owning a Tesla it's not
American made it wasn't made by the uh
UAW hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else